let's talk about what's happened the
latest limited information but what do
we do know
yeah it does look like the um the
Ukrainian counteroffensive has at least
started the UK media said that they have
made significant progress in some areas
of the front but actually that they've
also met pretty robust Russian defenses
in others
um as ever the ukrainians are being
absolutely silent if you recall
um president zlenski said Russia will
feel our offensive when it actually
starts so I think we're seeing the
openly Overture at the moment
interestingly President Putin has broken
with normal protocol he said no it's
it's definitely started our Russian
defenses are holding up really well and
we're inflicting massive casualties on
the Ukrainian forces as ever there's an
informational war going on here what's
interesting in the Russian military
bloggers that are often provide a little
bit more of a balanced view they are
significantly less positive about the
Russian performance so far if we look
though wider um there's also a whole
selection of Russian missile and drone
attacks that have been conducted across
the whole country if we look up and on
also the Russian Air Force for the first
time has been pretty active over the
southeast of the country free trying to
support its troops in kharkiv up to the
north there there were reports of 10
drone strikes one person killed three
people injured in that strike in the
polter region there is a military
Airfield there that apparently was
subjected to Russian military and sorry
Russian missile strikes and drone
strikes but apparently no casualties
there Ukraine's claim that they've shot
down 20 of the 35 drones and two of the
eight missile attacks but inevitably get
some get through and down the EU Odessa
is probably where the worst of the
damage appears to have been done
overnight there were three killed down
there in Odessa with a whole series of
drone and missile attacks the damage was
included 27 people uh wounded two
children and unfortunately one pregnant
woman in some of the footage that we've
seen from some of the devastation cores
not only by strikes but also some of the
falling wreckage It's Curious isn't it
because Russia is saying look we have
managed to inflict damage onto Western
and weaponry and what can we make of
that we take it with a pinch of salt
well past the Russian announcement
they've been very on the front foot of
announcing this stuff that obviously
they were very worried about the impacts
of Western Maine battle tanks so the
Russians have released video footage and
some Stills about some of this uh damage
that they've apparently inflicted on
Leopard 2 tanks first look as ever with
these imageries they're also very grainy
but if I if I look over here and look at
the actual Square here you can see this
is the the fire on apparently on the
attack I know it's grainy but Fire
doesn't appear in squares and it does
and if you look at the image carefully
it does look as if it's almost been
superimposed so I'm not entirely sure
what this is part of the information
award that's going on unfortunately
leopard twos the Ukraine had created
this in air of invincibility about
Western battle tanks and of course they
are vulnerable they're just a lot more
capable than most of the rest of the
tanks available now Ukraine are actually
operating on a broad Frontier they're
testing the Russian defenses once they
find a point of weakness of course
they'll use the tanks to punch through
but in the meantime any force on the
offense is suffering three times the
casualties of those on the defense so he
can expect to see quite a significant
uptick in the number of Ukrainian
casualties
inevitably the West hopes that this
Ukrainian offensive will be effective
and push the Russians back it might well
do but it's worth a caution note Russia
is a major superpower it's had many
months to prepare its defenses and
there's no doubt that in any type of War
it can be unpredictable so it's going to
be a very interesting next few days and
weeks so what of Ukraine then what will
they be looking to achieve with this
offensive and all-out win I think
there's three answers to that the first
answer is they mustn't lose I know that
might sound counterproductive but if
they throw themselves at the Russians
and don't make any breakthroughs at all
that will not only cause massive
casualties the ukrainians it will
significantly undermine the West
confidence it'll increase undermine
zelenski's morale and the people but
also Russia morale will increase and
then they'll potentially do a counter
attack the second thing they'll want to
do is to try to make sure that the David
that is Ukraine can push back the
Goliath that is Russia and actually push
back some of the Russian forces and make
at least some steady progress final sort
of ambition which is a sort of stretched
ambition is that they do some real
breakthrough and gain some momentum with
the punch through almost certainly the
main area will be around the Easter's
Apparition trying to push to the coast
and that would uh compromise the Russian
forces force them back into Crimea but
also they're moving around back moot at
the moment and it's quite possible the
Ukraine's will end up encircling uh back
mood whatever we can expect some pretty
Fierce fighting along the front line in
the coming days and weeks The Fortunes
will therein Hall the uncertainty is the
casualties figures are going to rise and
significantly